[Music]
marvel's avengers is a game which tries
to appeal to many types of gamers a
cinematic story with tons of set pieces
to a loot-based rpg with way more depth
than most people would expect
put bluntly marvel's avengers wants your
time for many years to come
and although nothing here is
revolutionary there is something very
special
in the making this is my 30-hour review
of marvel's avengers
to help you decide if this is the game
for you and spoiler alert
i like it
[Music]
marvel's avengers is split into two
elements the campaign and the online
co-operative rpg mode known as the
avengers initiative
both offer vastly different experiences
from the opening moments of the campaign
it's easy to see that this is a marvel
game made by fans
as everywhere we look we see easter eggs
and constant fan
service the main character of kamala
khan is a brilliant choice
to lead the reassembling of the avengers
after the events of ade
her positivity and constant fangirling
would usually be
an annoyance but kamala is written and
acted to perfection she's lovable and
her personality becomes infectious which
again comes down to the stellar writing
and voice acting on show here the
narrative
is another strong element as those
returning avengers
finally reunite to take down modok and
aim
and the cutscenes depict his slow
descent into madness taking many hours
to come to fruition
the story beats feel directly out of a
marvel comic book with each avenger
having their time to shine
in a campaign running around 8 to 10
hours in length
the avengers we play as all feel
drastically different and will
undoubtedly add replayability to both
the campaign
and the online avengers initiative for
example we don't get much of it but the
free running of captain america was
unlike any other character
and thor's fighting style well let's
just say if you liked playing as the god
of war on ps4 you'll feel right at home
with his abilities
throwing the ulna and summoning it back
to your hand never got old
and i played as thor for 20 hours
straight
similarly the super abilities of each
character felt distinctive
such as kamala's high five or black
widow's invisibility cloak
but here lies an issue how can hulk
smashing an enemy into oblivion
and a black widow punching a foe have
the same output
this really becomes an issue which
breaks the immersion
why does thor need to hit a henchman 12
times to take them down
this is the element of the game which
has been adapted to make all the
avengers as
balanced as possible even when it
doesn't seem like it should be
but if it didn't we'd all simply pick
hulk
marvel's avengers does attempt to keep
other areas of the law safe
using thor as an example his hammer
cannot be lifted by anyone
unworthy so when a hammer is on the
chest of an enemy
they are stuck there until thor sees fit
as we continue playing loot is thrown at
us each element of our character is
upgradable from
bracelets to bone density and everything
in between
but here's why that fails as a concept
nothing changes on the character at all
each new piece of gear we find
has zero impact on the aesthetics
for example we find the new chest piece
and apply it
and nothing happens it's all background
numbers and nothing is reflected in a
way which makes us want to chase the
loot
in other loot based video games each
item is reflected on your character
unlocking a full set of armor was a real
reward but here
this concept is tossed to the side for
something you may find sinister
or just another part of video games in
2020 a real money marketplace
in which outfits are bought and applied
to your characters
there are free versions too but at the
core the reason we don't see
iron man slowly evolve in game is to
incentivize us to buy a costume instead
and coincidentally there is a mission in
the game which perfectly sums up why
seeing our character armor update
is great by the time the credits roll
we've learned the basics of online play
using the war table to navigate and
continue
new elements of the story but right away
the story beats
evaporate there are cut scenes and
conjecture but the quality we saw in the
campaign
is nowhere to be seen now don't get me
wrong there are some inventive missions
but nothing comes close to that of the
campaign
and similarly the fighting mechanics we
learned over the story
are removed too take the taskmaster
fight at the start of the campaign
we learned to time a dodge and return
fire at the right moment
we learned how to attack with tactical
awareness and
now look at the task master boss fight
in the multiplayer portion
the difference is unnerving the fighting
online alongside other people
is boiled down to mindless bottom
bashing the abomination fight
is exactly the same there is a huge
weakness with online boss fights as
right now
the week of release there are no
mechanics in sight
if we take the game which is the closest
comparison destiny
who had a similar launch to this the
boss fights in there require precision
to find weak spots
they require knowledge of timing and
occasionally it was about being in the
perfect place
and understanding the boss's movements
but here in marvel's avengers
it's 10 minutes of spamming the buttons
and hoping you don't die
so you may think at this point that i
dislike this game when in fact
i think i'm addicted and it all comes
down to the loot system
we've looked at why it doesn't work in a
visual sense but underneath that
the depth of the loot system is
mind-blowing during the first 25 to
about 40 hours of your adventure you'll
simply be pressing one button to choose
the highest power level you can
the game relies on this system above all
else but then
once you've reached the end game content
no pun intended
your understanding of your inventory is
vital
visiting the frozen lands with an item
to stop you freezing your butt off
becomes integral
on the flip side having a weapon attack
that deals gamma damage
can make an impossible mission
accomplishable
the nuance of the loot system has a
great deal of potential
on top of this by unlocking skill points
in the game we can now change our super
abilities to function slightly different
they're only tweaks
but we can build a character unique to
us then the mastery of min
maxing comes in in which you build an
adventure designed for one single job in
a full team
be honest did that bore you to tears or
did that make you want to grind for loot
for me it's the latter i want to build a
thor that can one tap an enemy with a
hammer throw
without a doubt this is the appeal of
marvel's avengers power leveling a hero
and putting together six builds for
every fight you can imagine
reaching perfection is the goal here
i use destiny as the best parallel as to
the direction of marvel's avengers
both share huge similarities the world
has hubs to visit at present that's the
anthill and the chimera
in here we can see the faction system at
work as we pick up missions
and gear in a never-ending cycle of
incremental improvement
the mundane grind continues through
daily and weekly challenges
over my 20 hours online i played a
mixture of alone with people from my
discord
and other complete randoms too and once
again this is where the game felt great
the social aspect of games like this
can't be understated
a weekly meet up with friends as you
switch your brains off and finish
missions together
i played with one random guy for three
hours before they sent me a dm
and we'll likely play together again
soon there's something about games like
this like marvel's avengers that bring
people together
and as a guy who plays fortnite this
interaction
was humbling another aspect which may be
new to you
is um waiting yeah it's not great
on numerous occasions you will be
waiting in an elevator or sat
on the quinjet waiting for a mission to
begin it can feel like forever but once
again those people who play these types
of games
know that this is part of the cycle
things need to load and on console at
least
it takes a great deal of time i timed
one mission which had over three minutes
of load times either waiting in the
quinjet or hidden away in an elevator
next gen could help this issue i believe
but on the ps4 at least right now
waiting is not great here's the biggest
thing to take about the marvel's
avengers game
it isn't finished it will likely never
be finished and i know that sounds
strange
this is a game as a service which will
continually be
patched and iterated upon only this week
we found out that the new heroes are
coming which are clint and katie and
their hawkeye alter egos
those will be free updates which add a
backstory
hopefully to the quality of the campaign
and then they become whole new
superheroes we have to learn how to
fight with
and learn the skills of the thought of
shooting arrows in game right now
seems great and remember even more
characters are continually coming to the
game
whether that's black panther or if
you're on playstation we're gonna get
spider-man
by adding new characters the game
becomes increasingly replayable
and if we have a new superhero to flex
with then maybe we'll go out of our way
and use real money to buy a skin
too how do you feel about that so much
more is promised for the game and if
they get things right
marvel's avengers can be something very
very special
so to summarize the sublime story
content and top-notch voice acting the
set-piece boss fights in the campaign
bring marvel's characters to life
and the addictive loot system all makes
this game
a great experience right now but there
are weaknesses too with a focus on
monetizing customers who've already paid
full price for the game
through skins and emotes a lack of
challenge beyond button bashing online
and a monotony many people won't stick
around to play through
marvel's avengers is far from a final
version but the foundations in place
are strong my advice right now is to not
buy the game just yet
pick it up when more content is
available unless
you're into the loot grind like me and
if you are
i'll see you on the battlefield i'm adam
from playstation grenade
it's been a pleasure hopefully this has
helped in some way shape or form
i'll see you next time
you